oh we've got news from the literary
world
stacey abrams the governor of in
waiting in the state of georgia is in
her spare time
a naughty novel writer bodice rippers
they call them
steamy sexy and those books may soon be
coming to a bookstore near you fox's
trace gallagher has that story
trace and tucker if you were recently in
the market for a selena montgomery
romance novel like the art of desire
power of persuasion or rules of
engagement you could expect to pay
anywhere from 92 bucks
to 3 200 bucks a copy that's mostly
because the books are currently out of
print and because
steaming selena montgomery is actually
as you noted former
georgia gubernatorial candidate and
current political political activist
stacey abrams you know
romance writer turned political fighter
these days
abrams is known for using phrases like
moral imperative and equal justice but
during her time as stevie selena she
drew critical acclaim
and got hearts fluttering apparently
using words like
embracing bending brushing voracious and
turgid
which means big and despite having a pen
name stacey abrams isn't trying to shy
away from her
harlequin past in fact now that three of
the books are about to be reissued
abrams is trying to gin up interest by
noting that the novels showcase quote
women of color as nuanced determined and
exciting
the characters apparently work in a u.s
government espionage organization
and when they're not trying to save the
world from foreign adversaries
they can be found of course in the
throes of passion quoting here
in their kiss he tasted passion
forgotten chemistry
and her alarm at the loss of control he
felt her tremble
as he kissed her hand in the moonlight
not exactly going to make
philip roth blush but the reissued
novels
will be published under abram's real
name as well as her
gnome de plume tucker
you could do voice-overs that was
fantastic
softcore porn brought to you by trace
gallery probably not going to happen
thank you trace good to see you
so we call it steamy you heard a
selection from trace
we're getting our act together we've got
our producers on the case and we're
going to have some dramatic readings for
you because we can't we can't resist
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else